Happy New Year everybody welcome to 2015
2014 is officially done and gone but I
wanted to make a video that commemorated
the videos that I've made up to this
point and that was really hard because
the original video idea that I had was
to take one special moment from every
single video that I've ever done this
year not including the videos that I've
done for collabs and other people's
channels but the videos that I did on my
channel that marked my journey from
going from Cincinnati to coming to LA to
working with a bunch of new people and
doing all these really cool things but
that was hard so what I did instead is I
took some of the more special videos to
me and I took just about a second from
each of them to show you guys the
transition of where I came from to where
I am now and I'm watching this video as
you are now I'm just reviewing what I
cut together and it's really hard to
describe in words what it means to me to
see all this in one place because I said
before that I remember every single
video I've ever done but seeing them in
front of me and literally going through
every single video that I did this year
it was such a rush of emotions because
these may be videos for you and
entertainment for you but these are
moments of my life these are moments of
my life
all documenting this year and showing my
transition from start to finish you know
going from Cincinnati doing my farewell
livestream saying goodbye to my friends
and family and moving out here to LA so
I could pursue more opportunities here
and I'm so happy that I did I'm not
regretting that at all I miss my friends
and family dearly but I want to say that
you know I've improved as a person and
I've branched out a lot more and I've
discovered what I'm good at and what I'm
not good at and where my strengths are
and trying new video ideas and and
really experimenting with
is that you guys may have thought we're
really weird but you guys embraced it
and we're with me the whole way in and
that's what that's what means the most
to me you know I I never want to forget
a single person who has given me their
time or watched my videos or appreciated
what I've done and especially among my
friends but also among you guys and
that's what's really important to me for
this upcoming year because I I know that
I've been pretty lacks on content for
you guys some of you guys may not
realize it but I used to always upload
two videos every single day and that was
like a rule but as I got Betty busier in
LA and as I got more involved with out
the projects that weren't just my
channel and I was trying to do other
things and I was trying to move along
you know try to expand myself and what I
can do professionally I guess if you
want to call it that I I I feel like I
lost sight and this was a that's what I
was trying to say in the important
message video last month I was trying to
say that I can do more and that doesn't
mean that I can do more you know just in
general that means I can do more for you
guys and and I want to show you guys
that I still am 100% dedicated this
channel I mean I know that we've had
some incredible laughs and I've been
able to do some incredible things this
year and I've had so much fun doing it
and that's the thing I have so much fun
making these videos for you I have so
much fun playing with friends I have so
much fun being a goofball on camera for
you guys because it makes me laugh and
it makes me happy this channel makes me
happy and doing the dopey videos that
you guys love makes me so happy
and that's what I want to emphasize on
that's what I want to be able to do so
this is my new year's resolution for the
coming year because we're approaching
the end of the little montage that I had
and I I hope you guys understand that
you know this this montage is like so
important to me because every moment of
my life
up until this point and it's just about
to end because Here I am oh wait there I
am I'm done watching now but just thank
you guys so much for being there for me
this whole time and the most amazing
thing is that when I watch it from the
beginning to the end I expected there to
be a big change in myself and sure my
hair was shorter and I didn't have a
scruff on my face but you know I'm I'm
really happy to say that I don't
actually feel any older than I did when
I started I still feel like you know
this is the most fun job I've ever had
in my life and I never want to quit I
never in my life want to quit so this is
my new year's resolution I will always
always upload two videos a day and I'm
going to be more consistent about it
because that's been a big problem that
I've been critical of myself because I
haven't been consistent my content
people have said that they don't know
when a videos gonna come up so they
don't know when to check the channel so
it's always all over the place with my
videos sometimes I blowed late sometimes
I upload really early so I want to be
consistent about it and always have two
videos for you guys and always try
something new like on a regular basis
because that's what really makes me
excited to make videos is trying new
things so two videos a day first one's
gonna go up at 11 a.m. Eastern Standard
Time second one at 3 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time four hours apart that's 8
a.m. or and 12 noon if you're in Pacific
Standard Time
look it up online if you need to convert
to your timezone but that's what it's
always going to be starting tomorrow
because this video took way longer
I had to redownload a bunch of episodes
from YouTube I had to put it all in the
premiere and go to the process there
were days and weeks and weeks of video
content that I had to pour through but
it was all worth it because I needed to
see these
I needed to go through my little photo
album of my life and I needed to see
that this is the most important thing
that I can do and also I will be doing
many more charity events in the coming
of year I guess in 2015 not just in the
coming months as I was going to say I'm
going to definitely get back into the
swing of things and forget about the
other things that have been taking my
time that haven't been as important so
thank you guys so much so much for
watching I say that a lot and it's
practically a cliche at this point but
you guys are the most important thing in
my life and you will be for as long as
I'm still on YouTube so just thank you
guys I cannot wait I don't mean for this
to be a sappy sad video because I am
really happy right now
I had a vacation and I came back from it
and it's a new year and I feel so good
about what I can do and what I can make
and what I can create and what we can do
together and the amazing things that are
gonna come in this new year so thank you
guys everybody so much for watching you
are everything to me and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
bye